ce soir devant vous sur cette scène nous
sommes quatre en vrai on aurait pu être
sans même plus ça aurait été un peu le
bazar on serait serré mais on aurait pu
le faire
en revanche il y a une chose que nous
n'aurions pas pu faire c'est venir à un
seul car l'idée que nous vous présentons
ici est une idée collective
elle n'est la propriété de personne elle
appartient à toutes celles et ceux qui
trouvent une résonance un écho en elle
voilà ce soir nous vous emmenons devant
ce bâtiment
vous l'avez peut-être reconnu
l'assemblée nationale la maison du
peuple
c'est notre maison et nous les citoyens
on n'a pas les clés pourtant elle a une
importance folle cette assemblée
c'est elle qui contrôle le gouvernement
c'est elle qui votent les lois qui
régissent nos vies quand on passe devant
ce bâtiment ses portes fermées à double
tour contraste terriblement avec la
crise globale que traverse notre
civilisation une crise générale
financière économique sociale
environnementale
heureusement des alternatives existent
le monde évolue sans cesse de manière
totalement accélérer les verrous sautent
partout
entouré de ses mouvements de ses
accélérations la démocratie elle reste
immobile figé
nous vivons au 21ème siècle
mais cette institution fonctionne encore
avec des règles qui datent du 19e
c'est un peu anachronique c'est surtout
aberrant tous les cinq ans on part voté
on vote comme on peut à la
présidentielle puis aux législatives
parfois d'ailleurs on s'abstient au
final on se réveille toujours avec la
gueule de bois
une gueule de bois parce que une fois
que nous avons voté pour élire nos
députés
nous n'avons plus aucune prise sur eux
il décide seul
prennent parfois des décisions en allant
à l'encontre même de leurs propres
promesses
il cède aux compromis aux petits
arrangements
ils nous oublient les politiques sont
devenus des professionnels de leurs
propres intérêts alors on se demande
pourquoi encore voter puisque nous
savons que dans la foulée et pour les
cinq années qui suivent nous redevenons
simple spectateur cette gueule de bois
vous l'aurez compris elle vient d'un bug
le bug de la démocratie dite
représentative pour moi ce bug
je n'ai vraiment compris au moment du
référendum européen
ce jour là les parlementaires français
ont voté à l'encontre du texte que les
français avaient eux même refusé ce jour
là j'ai compris que nous n'étions pas
dans la démocratie à laquelle j'aspirais
pour moi ce fut un point de non retour
de mon côté ce bug
j'en ai pris conscience de manière
progressive je travaille avec des élus
et je ne peux pas me résoudre à ce que
la politique soit réservé à des gens
comme moi des professionnels des
techniciens des experts évidemment à
titre individuel on peut être plein de
bonne volonté mais collectivement on ne
peut pas continuer à avoir une telle
concentration des élites politiques
économiques et médiatiques pour moi le
bug
j'en ai fait l'expérience en tant que
militante associative
ça fait dix ans que je constate qu'à
l'assemblée nationale les dés sont pipés
les petits arrangements le clientélisme
voilà les dés sont pipés et nous les
citoyens nous sommes exclus des débats
les plus importants ceux qui régissent
tous les pans de notre vie de la
naissance à la mort et ça je ne peux pas
l'accepter
ce bug de la représentation moi ça fait
longtemps que je le ressens j'aime la
politique
j'ai toujours eu envie de m'engager et
pourtant je ne n'ai jamais fait en fait
je n'ai jamais voulu rejoindre des gens
persuadés de détenir la vérité d'avoir
raison contre tous les autres tout le
temps je ne voulais pas me mêler à ces
bagarres partisane stérile j'avais trop
peur de devenir un hooligan de la
politique
voici nos quatre témoignages quatre
parmi une multitude d'autres un moment
ou un autre on a tous eu ce déclic
le déclic c'est de constater ce bug est
ce dire ce système ne nous satisfait pas
bon maintenant on fait quoi on va pas
rester là sans rien tenter
on va pas cela c'est gagner par la peur
de l'autre le reclus repli
l'apathie la colère la frustration non
on a envie de tenter quelque chose
nous allons déconstruire analyser chacun
de ces bugs les égaux des querelles
partisanes stérile les parcours
individuels qui veulent tous dire une
chose la fin justifie les moyens
nous refusons cette phrase en bloc ce
qui compte pour nous c'est pas la
destination c'est le chemin alors nous
nous mettons en marche
nous allons reconstruire le monde tel
que nous le souhaitons oui c'est vrai on
a perdu toute envie d'élire mais nous
voulons voter plus que jamais pour
décider ensemble collectivement les
règles du jeu du vivre en société
alors nous nous sommes retrouvés autour
d'une idée nous allons hacker
l'assemblée nationale
vaste programme
pour y arriver nous allons porter à
l'assemblée nationale des citoyens
volontaires formés et tiré au sort qui
relaieront pendant cinq ans les
décisions de leurs électeurs
chacune de nos voix pour être entendue
et respectée
évidemment tout le monde ne votera pas
tout le temps pas sur chaque texte
pas sûr chaque loi mais le plus
important pour nous c'est que cette
possibilité existe que nous puissions
participer à chaque fois qu'une loi nous
touche nous révoltent ou nous passionne
alors pourquoi avoir choisi le tirage au
sort pour éviter les guerres d'ego qui
ravage le débat public
la personnification de la politique
n'est pas une fatalité et nous devons la
dépasser car la politique et la sphère
de tous
alors évidemment il va falloir nous
former pour être à l'aise lorsque nos
députés entreront à l'assemblée
nationale c'est pourquoi nous allons
vous proposer une formation civique
accessible à tous car si nous voulons
entrer dans le jeu il faut que nous en
connaissions les règles ma voix vous
l'aurez compris n'est pas un parti
politique n'a ni chef ni programme ma
voix c'est une méthode co construite par
toutes celles et tous ceux qui le
souhaitent y compris vous peut-être de
manière horizontale et coopératives
grâce aux nouveaux outils d'intelligence
collective pour la première fois nous
pouvons le faire sur le plan technique
la révolution numérique qui nous permet
d'échanger nos voitures nos appartements
nos photos nous permet aussi aujourd'hui
de discuter de débattre de délibéré de
prendre de meilleures décisions ensemble
ma voix c'est une expérience
et cette expérience elle se fonde sur la
confiance c'est à dire l'exact inverse
de l'image que nous renvoie sans cesse
nos dirigeants politiques eux ils misent
sur la méfiance
depuis longtemps il nous explique qu'on
est bien trop bête pour s'occuper de
questions si sérieuse ça leur permet de
nous dire ne vous inquiétez pas
laissez-nous faire on les a laissés
faire et on a la trouille
c'est sûr on n'est pas vraiment malin
mais franchement on fera difficilement
pire en tout cas avec ma voix on avance
en se faisant confiance confiance en soi
et confiance en les autres et cette
confiance
elle nous met tous face à notre
responsabilité individuelle et
collective c'est ce qui m'a plu et c'est
ce qui m'a donné envie de m'engager pour
la première fois de ma vie
moi ce qui me marque depuis le début de
cette aventure c'est que nous arrivons à
la faire fonctionner de manière
horizontale sans hiérarchie et ce qui me
fascine c'est la parole qui se libèrent
se soulage c'est tous ces citoyens qui
viennent à notre rencontre et qui nous
disent ici au moins on est à notre place
on nous laisse parler
on nous écoute alors on se met en
mouvement
on expérimente on avance pas à pas et
moi si je crois malgré quelques doutes
qui reste en nous si je crois à cette
expérience c'est parce que je sais
qu'elle est généreuse
or il n'ya pas que le oui le nom qui
compte le vote c'est le chemin le
processus le débat la construction c'est
tout cela la démocratie
en 2017 j'aurai trente ans et la vie
politique n'est pas tout à fait ce que
j'avais imaginé
alors ma voix ne servira pas tous mes
intérêts personnels
mais pour la première fois j'ai
l'impression que cette expérience ne
fera entrer chez nous à l'assemblée
nationale ma voix c'est une expérience
pour toutes celles et tous ceux qui
voudraient y contribuer dans toutes
leurs origines leur culture leur
histoire leur profession leur âge une
voix égale une autre voie on peut
participer un jour un mois 2 ans est ma
voix c'est l'engagement citoyen celui
qui nous oblige à sortir de notre zone
de confort aller à la rencontre de
l'homme la femme unique singulier dans
les bistrots dans les maisons de
quartier
aller à la rencontre de celles et ceux
qui avec qui a priori on ne partage rien
oui j'ai hâte tête ce dimanche de juin
2010 est dans l'isoloir pour la première
fois vis-à-vis de mes enfants je serai
fier de mon vote
ce sera ma façon à moi de leur dire que
la fatalité n'existe pas et qu'il faut
se mettre en chemin même quand tout
paraît bloquée
ma voix c'est ça des trajectoires
diverses des singularités qui
s'additionnent aux films du chemin tous
différents mais tous unis par une seule
et même envie expérimenter la démocratie
des citoyens de simples citoyens comme
nous comme vous à l'assemblée nationale
et pourquoi pas wikipedia aussi en 2001
paraissait complètement fou quand le
projet s'est lancé il n'y avait que les
experts qui rédigeaient les
encyclopédies et tout d'un coup tout le
monde peut contribuer à écrire la
connaissance à la partager projet à 15
ans et nous sommes des centaines de
millions d'utilisateurs aux quatre coins
du monde
ça touche tous les domaines les sciences
la médecine l'éducation les médias
pourquoi pas le monde politique alors
oui ma voix est une utopie pas dans le
sens où le projet irréalisable
tout simplement parce qu'il n'a pas
encore été réalisé alors c'est ce que
nous allons faire
humblement une pierre une contribution à
l'utopie de la démocratie dans le monde
entier des mouvements naissent répondant
tous la même soif de démocratie
allemagne mexique argentine venise
italie espagne islande grèce irlande
canada et dans des villes et villages
français partout dans le monde des
initiatives portent la volonté des
peuples à prendre leur place à la table
des décisions et nous ici sommes nous
prêts
merci